the minute she said it the temperature
in my classroom dropped my students are
usually laser focused on me but they
shifted in their seats and looked away
I'm a black woman who teaches the
histories of race and us slavery I'm
aware that my social identity is always
on display and my students are
vulnerable too so I'm careful I try to
anticipate what part of my lesson might
go wrong but honestly I didn't even see
this one coming
none of my years of graduate school
prepared me for what to do when the
n-word entered my classroom I was in my
first year of teaching when the students
said the n-word in my class she was not
calling anyone a name she was
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed she came to
class with her readings done she sat in
the front row and she was always on my
team when she said it she was actually
making a point about my lecture by
quoting a line from a 1970s movie comedy
that had two racist slurs one for people
of Chinese descent and the other the
n-word as soon as she said it I held up
my hands and say whoa whoa whoa but she
assured me it's a joke from Blazing
Saddles
and then she repeated it this all
happened ten years ago and how I handled
it haunted me for a long time it wasn't
the first time I thought about the word
in an academic setting I'm a professor
of US history it's it's in a lot of the
documents that I teach so I had to make
a choice after consulting with someone I
trusted I decided to never say it not
even to quote it but instead to use the
euphemistic phrase the n-word even this
decision was complicated I didn't have
tenure yet and I worried that senior
colleagues would think that by using the
phrase
I wasn't a serious scholar but saying
the actual word still felt worse the
incident in my classroom forced me to
publicly reckon with the word the
history the violence but also the
history the violence but also any time
it was hurled at me
spoken casually in front of me any time
it rested on the tip of someone's tongue
it all came flooding up in that moment
right in front of my students and I had
no idea what to do so I've come to call
stories like mine points of encounter a
point of encounter describes the moment
you come face-to-face with the n-word if
you've ever been stumped or provoked by
the word whether as the result of an
awkward social situation and
uncomfortable academic conversation
something you heard in pop culture or if
you've been called the slur or witnessed
someone getting called the slur you have
experienced a point of encounter and
depending on who you are and how that
moment goes down you might have a range
of responses could throw you off a
little bit or it could be incredibly
painful and humiliating I've had lots of
these points of encounter in in my life
but one but one thing is true
there's there's not a lot of space to
talk about them right that day in my
classroom was pretty much like all of
those times I had an uninvited run-in
with the N word I froze because the N
word is hard to talk about part of the
reason the N word is so hard to talk
about is usually only discussed in one
way as a figure of speech we hear this
all the time right it's just a word the
burning question that cycles through
social media is who can and cannot say
it black intellectual Tana Hussey Coates
does a groundbreaking job of defending
the african-american use of the word on
the other hand Wendy kaminer a white
freedom of speech advocate argues that
if we
don't all just come out and say it we
give the word power and a lot of people
feel that way the Pew Center recently
entered the debate in a survey called
race in America 2019 researchers asked
US adults if they thought it was ok to
for a white person to say the n-word 70
percent of all adults surveyed said
never and these debates are important
but they really obscure something else
they keep us from getting underneath to
the real conversation which is that the
n-word is not just a word it's it's not
neatly contained in a racist past a
relic of slavery fundamentally the
n-word is an idea
disguised as a word that black people
are intellectually biologically and
immutably inferior to white people and
and I think this is the most important
part that that inferiority means that
the injustice we suffer an inequality we
endure is essentially our own fault
so um yes it is
speaking of the word only as racists pew
or as an obscenity in hip-hop music
makes it sound as if it's a disease
located in the American vocal chords
that can be snipped right out it's not
and it can't and I learned this from
talking to my students so next time
class met I apologized and I made an
announcement I would have a new policy
students would see the word in my
powerpoints in film in essays they read
but we would never ever say the word out
loud in class nobody ever said it again
but they didn't learn much either
afterwards what bothered me most was
that I didn't even explain to students
why of all the vile problematic words in
American English why this particular
word had its own buffer a surrogate
phrase the n-word most of my students
many of them born in the late 1990s and
afterwards didn't even know that the
phrase the n-word is a relatively new
invention in American English when when
I was growing up it didn't exist but in
the late 1980s black college students
writers intellectuals more and more
started to talk about racist attacks
against them but increasingly when they
told these stories they stopped using
the word instead they reduced it to the
initial end and called it the n-word
they felt that every time the word was
uttered it opened up old wounds so they
refused to say it they knew their
listeners would hear the actual word in
their heads that wasn't the point the
point was they didn't want to put the
word in their own mouths or into the air
by doing this they made an entire nation
start to second-guess themselves about
saying
this was such a radical move the people
are still mad about it critics accuse
those of us who use the phrase the
n-word or people who become outraged you
know just because the word is said of
being over principled politically
correct or as I just read a couple of
weeks ago in the New York Times
insufferably woke right so so I bought
into this a little bit too which is why
the next time I taught the course I
proposed a freedom of speech debate the
N word in academic spaces for or against
I was certain students would be eager to
debate who gets to say it and who
doesn't but they weren't instead my
students started confessing a white
student from New Jersey talked about
standing by as a black kid at her school
got bullied by this word she did nothing
and years later still carried the guilt
another from Connecticut talked about
the pain of severing a very close
relationship with a family member
because that family member refused to
stop saying the word one of the most
memorable stories came from a very quiet
black student from South Carolina she
didn't understand all the fuss she said
everyone at her school said the word she
wasn't talking about kids calling each
other name in the hall she explained
that at her school when teachers and
administrators became frustrated with an
african-american student they called
that student the actual n-word she said
it didn't bother her at all but then a
couple of days later she came to visit
me in my office hours and wept
she thought she was immune she realized
that she wasn't over the last ten years
I have literally heard hundreds of these
stories from all kinds of people from
all ages people in their 50s remembering
stories from the second grade and when
they were six either calling people the
word or being called the word but
carrying that all these years around
this word you know and as I listen to
people talk about their points of
encounter what the pattern that emerge
for me as a teacher that I found most
upsetting is the single most fraught
sight for these points of encounter is
the classroom most us kids are going to
meet the n-word in class one of the most
assigned books in u.s. high schools is
Mark Twain's The Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn in which the word
appears over 200 times and and this is
an indictment of Huck Finn the word is
in lots of US literature in history it's
all over African American literature
yet I hear from students that when the
word is said during a lesson without
discussion and context it poisons the
entire classroom environment the trust
between student and teacher is broken
even so many teachers often with the
very best of intentions still say the
n-word in class they want to show and
emphasize the horrors of us racism so
they rely on it for shock value invoking
it brings into stark relief the ugliness
of our nation's past but they forget the
ideas are alive and well in our cultural
fabric
the six letter word is like a capsule of
accumulated hurt every time it is said
every time it releases into the
atmosphere the hateful notion that black
people are less my black students tell
me that when the word is quoted or
spoken in class they feel like a giant
spotlight is shining on them one of my
students told me that his classmates
were like bobble heads turning to gauge
his reaction a white student told me
that in the eighth grade when they were
learning to kill a mockingbird and
reading it out loud in class the student
was so stressed out at the idea of
having to read the word which the
teacher insisted all students do that
that the the student ended up spending
most of the unit hiding out in the
bathroom
this is serious students across the
country talk about switching majors and
dropping classes because of poor
teaching around the N word the issue of
faculty carelessly speaking the word has
reached such a fevered pitch it's led to
protests at Princeton Emory the new
school Smith College where I teach and
Williams College where just recently
students have boycotted the entire
English department over it and other
issues and these are just the cases that
make the news this is a crisis and while
student reaction looks like an attack on
freedom of speech I promise this is an
issue of tea of teaching my students are
not afraid of materials that have the
n-word in it they want to learn about
James Baldwin and William Faulkner and
about the civil rights movement in fact
their stories show
this word is a central feature of their
lives as young people in the United
States it's in the music they love and
in the popular culture they emulate the
comedy they watch it's in TV and movies
and memorialized in museums they hear it
in locker rooms on Instagram in in the
hallways at school and the chat rooms
are the video games they play it is all
over the world they navigate but they
don't know how to think about it or even
really what the word means I didn't even
really understand what the word meant
until I did some research I was
astonished to learn that black people
first incorporated the n-word into the
vocabulary as political protest not in
the 1970s or 1980s but as far back as
the 1770s and I wish I more time to talk
about the long subversive history of the
black use of the n-word but I will say
this many times my students will come up
to me and say I understand the virulent
roots of this word it's slavery they're
only partially right this word which
existed before it became a slur but it
becomes a slur at a very distinct moment
in US history and that's as large
numbers of black people begin to become
free starting in the north in the 1820s
in other words this word is
fundamentally an assault on black
freedom black mobility and black
aspiration even now nothing so swiftly
unleashes an n-word tirade as a black
person asserting their rights or going
where they please or prospering think of
the attacks on Colin Kaepernick when he
kneeled or Barack Obama when he became
president my students want to know this
history but when they ask questions
their shush
and shamed by shying away from talking
about the n-word we have turned this
word into the ultimate taboo crafting it
into something so tantalizing that for
all us kids no matter their racial
background part of their coming-of-age
is figuring out how to negotiate this
word we treat conversations about it
like sex before sex education
we're squeamish we silence them so they
learn about it from misinformed friends
and in whispers I wish I could go back
to the classroom that day and push
through my fear to talk about the fact
that something actually happened not
just to me or to my black students but
to all of us you know I think in we're
all connected by our inability to talk
about this word but what if we explored
our points of encounter and did start to
talk about it today I try to create the
conditions in my classroom to have open
and honest conversations about it one of
those conditions not saying the word
we're able to talk about it because it
doesn't come into the classroom another
important condition is I don't make my
black students responsible for teaching
their classmates about this that is my
job
so I come prepared I hold the
conversation with a tight rein and I'm
armed with knowledge of the history I
always ask students the same question
why is talking about the n-word hard
their answers are amazing they're
amazing more than anything though I have
become deeply acquainted with my own
points of encounter my personal history
around this word because when the n-word
comes to school or really anywhere it
brings with it all of the complicated
history of us racism the nation's
history
and my own right here right now there's
no avoiding it